- [Kelly] So your new shows
are about cars and renovations.
So who's better at cars?
- [Drew] At cars?
- Not you.
- Clearly not you..
(laughing)
- I'm good at cars, I do cars.
- I am Ron burgundy,
I just read what was in the prompter.
(laughing)
- [Jonathan] Let me tell
you how it came to be.
So Celebrity IOU, we we've
done with the renovations
for quite a long...
and it's been very successful
and we thought this is a format
that could work really really well
with cars as well,
and there are so many celebrities
who were obsessed with cars,
but also want to find a way to give back.
- And, you know,
so we have a really good friend,
Ant Anstead,
he's one of the biggest
names in the car space,
along with Christie Lee,
they're just known for
cars and, make-overs.
And so Ants helping me
with "Drew's Dream Car".
He's helping me create
my childhood dream car.
I wanted a classic European sports car,
but I wanted it electric
'cause I love electric
- oh, yeah
- anyway, so it's a, it was a fun process.
I said, hey,
the way we help celebrities
give back to someone
that they really love on our show
with the renovations
would you want to work with us
on doing that for celebrities with cars?
And if you've seen Octavia Spencer
and James Martin,
- That had me in tears,
yeah that was so sweet.
- Renee Zellweger giving back
to the nurses that worked
with her, her publicist's best friend,
it's so heartwarming to
see these stories so...
- and it's, it's on Discovery Plus.
It's not just for gearheads.
It's not just for people who love cars.
It's for people who just
love those emotional stories.
- [Kelly] Yeah, and just have hearts.
Yeah, Yeah
- [Drew] Yeah, we all have hearts.
- We were gonna approach
Whitney, but after this today...
(laughing)
(clapping)
- No heart, no heart.
- [Audience] (clapping)
(cheering)
- No, comedians,
- [Audience] (clapping)
comedians are the ones...
- [Jonathan] Hollow in there..
- [Kelly] Actually...No, no...
- No, it's not hollow that's silicone,
- [Kelly] (laughing)
it's hardened silicone.
- (Kelly) No, I will tell you,
I was the cocktail waitress,
and I'm telling you that at a comedy club,
comedians...
it's funny 'cause first of all,
they are usually the smartest people,
because they're very witty,
but also you do have the most depth.
- [Audience] (cheering)
(clapping)
So I think that you would be...
I think you... love to be playful,
but I think you have a
lot of depth as well.
- No we just have bad childhoods
and we're desperate...
we're desperate to be loved,
- [Kelly] (laughing)
but we push it away
and make ourselves unlovable
(laughing)
just to stay in the...
Possible...
(laughing)
(clapping)
- [Kelly] Look, it's the touch me tour.
It's the touch me tour, guys.
- There it is, yeah...
- [Audience] (clapping)
(cheering)
Oh, you guys,
lets all get COVID.
- No, that's you... back over there.
- Okay, sorry, sorry
- NO!
(laughing)
- I will point out by the way,
we've known this one for a very long time
and she is amazing.
[Kelly] Yeah, hilarious.
- My wife and I will sit
and cry while we watch your podcast
half the time it's tears of joy
and other times it's just...
- You just want it to be over?
(laughing)